this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's going to be taking a look
at the post-apocalyptic weaponry
of the metro franchise this is what i
kind of expected to see in a series like
metro
a really basic form of shotgun believe
it or not we actually have something
very similar
here at the royal armouries if there are
any other guns games or mechanics that
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
[Music]
all right paul's there i'm a few seconds
in and i've already seen something
the weapon itself is pretty intriguing
it's obviously a shotgun
mainly tell that because it's got actual
shotgun cartridges visible
and that's um probably the main issue
with the design
revolver this is a revolver shotgun
revolvers of whatever type
they have a cylinder um or they might
operate with an external
drum system but there isn't anything to
contain
the rounds now it looks like there is a
bolt that is
ramming the cartridge into the chamber
from this
for once of a better term clip if so
then
it could work but you still wouldn't i
don't think you'd want a magazine system
that doesn't protect the rounds it's a
bit of a weird one
i think it's been done for visual
interest so that you can see the rounds
creative doesn't seem very practical so
it's unlike most revolver shotguns
which are typically like a revolving
pistol they have a
solid cylinder board with chambers and
the rounds
are fired within the chambers so the
chamber forms the back of the barrel the
breach
this isn't that this is more like a
semi-automatic shotgun combined with a
revolver shotgun
we have a recognizable member of the
kalashnikov family there
kind of functions as you would expect it
to except for the
the reload seems a little a little janky
it's very quick so it's hard to be sure
but it looks like that
fresh magazine is just getting jammed
into the magazine well those of you who
know your aks know that
the front has to go in first or you have
the embarrassing situation of your
magazine falling out
we've got some different types of
ammunition going on here look to be
incendiary literally setting on fire the
enemies that were being shot
the magazine looked like it was open on
the side which is
probably a gameplay thing so that you
you know for sure what sort of
rounds you're loading but um in the real
world is a bad idea because you're going
to get all sorts of crud
into the magazine that will stop those
rounds from feeding up into the weapon
now this is what i kind of expected to
see in a series like metro
a really basic improvised form of
shotgun
and we've got at least two versions here
double-barreled and
uh quad barrel believe it or not we
actually have something very similar
here at the royal armories and well we
have a number of improvised shotguns but
none of them are
quite as much like the metro design
as this one so it's got a latch on the
top and then it
breaks open like many shotguns do like
the one in the game does
when you open the gun in the game
cartridge cases go flying out
in reality when you open this gun this
would happen
because there's nothing hooking under
that rim to pull out the case so that
you can
remove it and there's certainly not a
mechanism usually a plunger type
mechanism
spring-loaded that actually kicks the
cartridge case
flying out of the gun the other
consideration with a shotgun is recoil
the double barrel if you're firing both
barrels at once
is a real handful four barrels going off
at once
is serious business and i don't think
i've seen a four four-barrel shotgun
fired
but um you'd need to practice and you'd
probably need to be
physically bigger than me to do that
right well this this is a fun one it's
another shotgun but it's um a belt-fed
automatic shotgun reminiscent of things
like the
ags-17 but for 12-gauge cartridges
so it looks plausible enough in terms of
how it's designed
the function of it is bizarre because it
looks like we've got a two fire modes
one of them is like a burst but then
after the burst the animation is
lifting the top cover fiddling with it
and closing it again almost like it's
jamming so i don't
i really don't know what's going on
there i quite like how
wobbly the um top cover is not not that
that would be
particularly plausible because something
that wobbles around that much probably
wouldn't work properly but um
it does it does fit the idea of this
being homemade
right i gather this is a bit of a staple
of the metro games
it's uh interesting i've heard it
compared to the sten gun but it's
really not much like a stand gun other
than being an apparently
blowback operated submachine gun the
only one we see a real detail
look at is the the most recent and
that's got no visible cocking handle
other than the disc at the rear that
gets pulled when there's a jam when
there's a stoppage
but then that never gets pulled when the
weapon's just being loaded
so how are we cocking the bolt uh the
whole feed mechanism is just
bonkers i don't want to be the guy that
has to load those
skeleton clip things because it i don't
even know how it keeps the rounds in
there much less how you'd actually get
them in there
that system seems to be inspired by
things like the hotchkiss
strip fed machine guns where you have a
sheet metal clip with bits pressed out
of it that hold the rounds
this is more like a cage that encloses
the rounds which i haven't seen
done before it has all the disadvantages
of an open sided magazine
it's somehow driven through the gun so
it has no spring
inside it to actually push the rounds
across so it's kind of a fascinating
family of weapons that they've developed
here but it's doesn't have any close
real world parallel
the gun i've grabbed behind me there is
the ppd34
and it's only really similar in the
vague shape of the receiver and the fact
that it's russian
and it has cooling slots in the barrel
you will you won't find
anything very close to this yeah i've
just got some problems with that feed
device i'm afraid
wow uh where to start with this thing
so it's clearly a kalashnikov barrel and
gas system it's not it's an ak-74
muzzle break and then it all goes wrong
from there
it this thing really wants to be a p90
for some reason
the sort of carrying handle housing
looks very p90
the top mounted magazine with the sort
of transverse
feed is is taken from the p90 as is the
rear of the stock
but then instead of a clear polymer
magazine it's literally just got a hole
cut in it like the normal ak mags have
not a good idea and i think what blows
my mind the most about this
is that it it's a bullpup but it's kind
of
a half-assed ballpark because the firing
grip
is quite far to the rear too far to the
rear in fact
so the the firing grip should be the
front one that would make sense that
would that would give you the long
barrel in a short
overall length which is the whole point
of a ballpark having the foregrip that
far
back and the firing grip even further
back gives you an incredibly
short what we call length of pull which
is not very comfortable
and if the cartridge has any real recoil
to it even less comfortable because it's
effectively a very short
stock and doesn't take full advantage of
making it evolve up so it just
it doesn't work on a number of levels
yeah i hate it
sorry
can i firstly just say that i do
appreciate the wiping the blood
off the face or visor that's that's a
nice touch
and it kind of fits with this weapon
because it's clearly so powerful it
creates a it's not even a pink mist it's
just like a red cloud
it's obviously meant to be a very
powerful round bolt action weapon
typically in a game dictates high power
uh this is
very similar to as you can't really miss
behind me
the ptrd a 1941 design
for an extremely powerful anti-tank
rifle if you're using it against
personnel
especially if they're behind a wall of
any kind and you know they're there you
can just buy
straight through it i'm not quite sure
how cover and concealment works
in this game but i wouldn't be surprised
if that's not an advantage
of it it's also substantially smaller
and lighter than the actual ptrd
which is as you can see immense and
extremely heavy
it's not something you you could
realistically carry and shoot
well you could pick it up and fire
around from the hip
but you're not going to hit anything
i'm seeing a lot of improvements here in
the more recent
uh installment in the series in terms of
how the kalashnikov is
is represented or kalash as it's called
in in these games
the way the design is depicted is more
in line with
its real world counterpart it's a bit
less stylized
it's still still a sort of mishmash of
different styles so we've got the groove
in the buttstock of the ak-74
they've gone for a modular kit bash
approach which
makes lots of sense in this setting and
is very popular
in more recent years as well of course
some sort of gunsmith so we see
different
front ends just magically being swapped
in you can absolutely do that but it
would require quite a lot of gunsmithing
ability
in common with a couple of other more
recent games you can you can leave bits
off so we see the
the ak taken into the metro there with
no top cover on it
which always looks a bit weird but works
all that is is a dust cover
so definitely works without it
this is a bit of a change of pace we've
got an airgun the airgun
reverts you not not to me not to muzzle
loading technology
you're still going to be loading from
the bridge what we see here
but you end up with a separate
propellant
system and feed system so you've no
longer got your
propellant in a cartridge what you need
for something that's actually capable of
killing
is an air reservoir or a gas canister
much like we see here and some of them
do have that pressure
gauge on there so that you know how much
charge you've got left
at a given air pressure because if it
falls below a certain air pressure
it's not going to be lethal and we see
that in the gameplay so it's very
loosely based on present day
air gun technology so hints of hints of
what we have now
but in a package that looks like nothing
you've ever seen pretty much it looks
uh it's very reminiscent of the fallout
games of course but
perhaps the laser weapons in that
we've got a revolver and heavily
customized
in-game to essentially revolve a
revolving carbine revolving rifle the
reason i've grabbed this it doesn't look
particularly like
the revolver in the game which is
unnamed but it does borrow heavily from
the smith and wesson number three and
i've grabbed this one
specifically well for two reasons one is
it does take the
the frame of the revolver appears to be
what they're using in
metro and if you look at the the side
plate
very closely you'll see it's this
removable side plate which is how you
access the mechanism to repair it
maintain it is the same shape it even
has the same three screws
so this was the visual reference or one
of this family
was the visual reference for the
revolver in the game one of the
upgrades we saw there was a sound
suppressor
on a revolver which is normally a no no
because you have the gap
between cylinder and barrel
just in there very small but enough for
extra sound to leak out to put it that
way
now where that does work is with the
appropriately russian nagant revolver
which was designed to have a cylinder
that
ratchets forward and seals against the
back of the barrel
using the mouth of the case and the
bullets recessed it's telescoped
and so that seals that gap and so that
is a revolver that has been
uh suppressed typically you're not
suppressing revolvers
if you'd like to support our work at the
royal armouries we've got
links in the description as to how you
can do that but i'll uh
otherwise see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you